- Hey guys it's Justine.
And today I am so excited
because we are in the bathroom
doing a very special
unboxing of this right here.
This is the Naked 3D Body Scanner.
Now it sounds a little scandalous.
But, I think one of the
most important things
to keep in mind is when
you are on some sort of
fitness journey,
whether you're trying to
lose weight, build muscle.
Being able to take all of your
measurements into account,
just not weight,
is something that is very, very important.
So, with this, you're gonna be
able to get a very, extremely
accurate representation
of your current body
and track your progress
just using your phone.
Okay, should we get started Jen?
- [Jen] Oh yeah.
- Oh boy.
This is something that has
been in development since 2015
and guess what?
Pre orders are finally shipping
and we're gonna be unboxing one right now.
(tape ripping)
Please download the Naked
app before unboxing.
I already didn't follow the instructions.
(mellow music)
This is a huge box.
Here we are.
This is the mirror portion
of this whole contraption.
Oh, wow, wow, wow!
So, these run about
$1,300, shipping is $100.
Hmm.
(styrofoam rustling)
Looks like we have several,
pieces here.
But, it doesn't look like installation
is gonna be very difficult.
Wow!
This is heavy.
- [Jen] Never cut towards yourself.
(giggles)
- Never cut towards yourself.
I'm still doing it.
Shoot.
Cut away.
I am dusting the floor.
First of all.
This is packaged is very nice.
Whoa!
This looks nice!
This is something that I
wished that I would've had,
I guess probably the end of February?
I am not proud of it, but
I really didn't work out
for about two years.
I was probably in the absolute
worst shape of my life.
Jenna can definitely
vouch for that because the
first hike that we went on,
I thought I was dying.
I actually thought I was
having a heart attack.
I was like looking at my Apple Watch and
I was like I don't think I'm well.
So, I am still in the early stages
of my fitness journey here.
So, this is gonna be cool to kind of,
track my current progress.
The progress that I had previous,
I was using one of the
regular wifi scales.
So, I have that data.
But, I'm not sure how accurate that is
because those are really only
able to track your weight.
They say that they can
kind of take into account,
like your body mass.
But, I'm not sure how that all works.
What else is in here?
Carpet feet.
So, it looks like you can use this on
different types of floors.
Wow, is this heavy.
So, this is why it's so heavy.
Holy,
moly!
I'd say this is about,
15 pounds.
Carpet feet.
Look at that!
These are little carpet feet.
I'm not gonna be putting this on carpet.
(plastic rustling)
This looks so good.
So this is why it tells
you to download the app
before you unbox it.
I've got that one.
It's telling you not to
set it up by the shower.
And guess what I have done.
(laughs)
- [Jen] You're not gonna
leave it there though.
- I'm not gonna be leaving it here,
but just for the sake of the demo.
I do have it next to the shower.
But, this is something that
you are not supposed to do.
It says that moisture
can damage Naked sensors.
For the sake of this
video, we set up here.
I will be moving it.
But to where I've left off.
Now, I've learned all the
things that I've done wrong.
Hmmm.
(tapping)
Definitely download the app
before you open the box.
I'm doing what I was supposed
to do the first time.
This is very
well designed.
Like really cool.
So with the intel x86
processor, four gigs of RAM,
and the intel realsense 3D depth cameras,
this gives you enough power to give you
some very high resolution
3D scans of your body.
Oh look, you charge the
scale through the mirror.
There's USB-C at the bottom.
I didn't even know that was under there.
Please make sure that the
mirror and USB are connected.
Okay it is.
This will take about 10 minutes.
Please make sure your scanner
and scale are connected.
Do I need to stay here?
No, you're free to roam about your home.
Alright!
- [Jen] Where you gonna go?
- [Justine] I don't know.
Probably sit here and watch it.
- [Jen] Oh cool!
- [Justine] It's been updated.
We didn't do anything since.
Unplug and now store the charging table.
Okay.
Congrats, now go take your first scan.
Alright.
Oh.
Oh!
Loose clothes, jeez.
- [Jen] You're covered head
to toe with clothes right now.
- [Justine] I know.
Hair, I gotta pull my hair up, okay.
I'll pull my hair up,
but I'm not gonna take my clothes of yet.
(laughs)
It's not gonna be the best scan,
but it's gonna be the test.
On the next step,
a red laser will shine
down from the mirror.
No way!
This is what!?
So move for the scale,
so the laser hits the mark on the scale.
No freaking way.
- [Jen] This is the coolest
thing. I've ever seen.
- This is so crazy.
Here I was trying to measure,
to make sure I had it perfectly in line.
Position the scale marker
in the middle of your feet.
Step one, you have six seconds okay.
Don't move or talk.
(upbeat music)
(machine whirring)
I can't see my phone.
- [Jen] Get off.
- Okay.
(giggles)
Checking your scan.
Step off, but don't touch
the scale for three seconds.
Says there's a lot
happening behind the scenes.
Every scan is first
processed in the mirror
and then uploaded to the Naked cloud
then downloaded onto your phone.
The depths censors capture
four gigabytes of raw data
that must be compiled in the mirror.
Here's my body with all my clothes on.
You can go in and check your measurements.
My left arm.
My right arm.
Oh, this is a lot of information.
So, this is my first scan with clothes on.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that hair.
I mean it picks up every little crease
in the clothing.
I can't even imagine
what it's gonna pick up
on the actual body.
Here's all the views.
This is nuts!
Oh my gosh.
Okay, now I need to find something to wear
and scan my actual
body.
I'm sorry that you have
to witness this Jenna.
(groans)
So, now it's time to do the Naked scan,
sort of naked.
Not too excited about this,
but we're gonna do it,
and see what happens.
(upbeat music)
Here we go.
This is so detailed.
Oh look at this.
You can tag good day, bad
day, diet, special event.
So, this does really give you sort of an
extreme, accurate representation
of where you started
and where you are currently.
What I really love about this,
is your comparing yourself to yourself.
Every body is different.
People gain and lose weight differently.
People gain muscle mass differently.
So, comparing yourself to
someone else is really not
a very fair comparison.
With this comparing yourself to yourself.
Is one of the best ways
to be able to track your fitness goals.
Let me know what you guys
do for fitness activities.
Is it hiking?
Is it running?
Is it doing something else really cool?
Let me know, I would love
to hear from you guys.
With that,
I think I'm gonna go put this somewhere,
where it's not next to the shower.
And that's it.
I'm gonna try sink.
I'll see you later.
Jen do you wanna get naked.
- [Jen] Yeah!
- Cool.
This thing really is neat.
(mellow music)